welcome to doorman products installation
video for programming keyless entry
remote on 2013 through 2016 Nissan
Altima and 2013 through 2015 Nissan
Pathfinder models this installation is
considered easy and should take less
than 10 minutes to perform before you
begin this programming procedure be sure
you have all remotes for the vehicle
present this procedure must be followed
precisely failing to do so could result
in a non functioning vehicle also be
aware the programming device may only be
used for three programming attempts
after which it will no longer be able to
be used if you experience difficulties
with this procedure or have further
questions call our help line at one
eight hundred five two three two nine
one one with the driver's door open make
sure your feet are completely off the
brake pedal press the start/stop engine
twice and then turn the hazard lights on
plug the programmer into the OBD port
located below the steering column it
should beat twice to confirm it is
active press the start/stop Engine
button once to the off position the
programmer will beep once the car is now
ready to program your remotes to begin
programming pull the remote in front of
the start/stop engine with your foot off
the brake pedal press the start/stop
button once the red car light on the
dashboard will flash five times press
the start/stop Engine button to the off
position to set the program
additional remotes can be programmed by
repeating the previous steps all
additional remotes need to be programmed
at this time when all remotes are
programmed press the start/stop Engine
button to the on position making sure
your feet are off the brake pedal press
the start/stop button to the off
position the message in the instrument
cluster should read key registration
complete test the functionality of each
remote by starting the vehicle as normal
if programming has failed restart the
instructions from the beginning if you
experience difficulties with this
procedure or have further questions call
our help line at one eight hundred five
two three two nine one one and don't
forget to always check Dorman first for
your automotive repair solutions